the business stories are people are
escaping all kinds of persecution in the
homeland yes because of who they are and
because of climate change even want to
have a better work on themselves and for
their children and that's those are so
primary desire of all human beings it's
just that in the world today when our
national borders we are closing those
doors and therefore refugees and asylum
seekers have become an issue but some
seekers and refugees are not asking for
a handout there are simply people
migrating to a better place
to make life better for their children
and their family they want to be free I
mean this is our human spirit we all
want to be free in whatever way you do
it I'm not putting up a political term
tree they want to be free to be happy to
be able to support themselves explore
the world have a chance for their
imagination to to to to bloom so I think
this is a basic human spirit you're
using anthropology to go into doing work
that assists the asylum seekers who are
seeking refuge someone's opinion me
contradict yours what is my friend Allen
it's all about your perspective who are
we and what is the nature of this
reality
[Music]
what's up everyone welcome to simulation
I'm your host Don Satya
we are still on site at the American
Anthropological Association Annual
Meeting in Vancouver British Columbia
this is our second partnership with them
we are now going to be speaking with dr.
chor Swan I mean I saw on hi good
morning thank you for coming on our
program thank you for having me and
congratulations on your new book
identities on trial in the United States
you've been professing for a long time
26 years at Cal State Los Angeles you
also founded the Asian and Asian
American Studies triple-a s program at
CSULA and this new book is really
profound about the radical shifts the
radically shifting the asylum seeking
narrative and I'm really excited to dive
into it I want to ask you one of our
favorite questions that we asked on the
show do you think that we're really all
one yes of course the refugees and
asylum seekers are no different from us
we are all one we are all part of the
human condition and what is the most
upstream issue that we face is it our
feelings of separation from each other
and from nature this feeling this lack
of interconnectedness I think we are
very connected refugees and asylum
seekers are knocking on our doors and
what do we do oh that we need to do is
just open the door we are one we are
really one and in a way we could ask the
question why are we knocking on our
doors the doors of OCAD Western
democracies and that's because there are
problems in the world I think if we
don't see them as in a negative way if
we see them as people who are
questioning the system that's not right
in the world then we all want all of us
inside behind this door are also
searching for a better world and finding
better answers for all of us in the
world yes yes architecting the next
world that maximizes flourishing for all
of us and what is it about this from
very like macro-level perspective from a
very historical context it doesn't even
seem like there were ever any borders
that there were ever any tribes that
this has always been just a human tribe
and then over time it became borders
with resources with governments with
hierarchies with tribes with now there's
an asylum seeker that and and they even
have to knock and that even with the
more enlightened we are the less we even
have war and conflict that causes asylum
seeking has that been a pretty common
theme is that is it war and conflict
that causes people to asylum seeker in
the first place
there are two parts to it if you look at
the world historically people have
always searched for refuge in the
Arabian Peninsula in the past people
knock on doors and and in the past
people provided hospitality in their
tents for people who escaped
difficulties in their tribe and in the
homeland today we have the same
mechanism but it's more tests that's all
so the question is do we have the same
hospitality but those who are seeking
help if you think about the major
religions in the world we have always
given help to other people
so given hospitality and help is a human
value it's a human condition that we
have always done and the fact that we
are closing more doors of course the
government's can say we are overwhelmed
by all these refugees coming to our
country they can always say they are in
various negative terms
that is the current condition okay we
can go into why those things happen but
in terms of the larger picture we have
always been asking for help and
hospitality and given hospitality at the
same time so this is no different yeah I
love those two words help in hospitality
so over time there's always been since
the dawn of time there's always been
times of people coming and asking for
help in other people providing
hospitality and that's been a major
aspect of our cooperation that's been
our social bonding and our ability to do
that process of maximizing flourishing
just making it so that people feel loved
and that being a really rooted principle
I like that a lot helped in hospitality
now what is you know it does seem like
there's a mainstream media fear-based
narrative that is propagated and also
you can kind of see in some levels of
chill childhood consciousness that
children that are born with other
children around them of different
religions or skin colors and all these
different types of things end up being
more open they have a deeper level of
openness and then kind of like the more
archaic older consciousness that maybe
still has a little bit more fear
xenophobia things like this do you kind
of see a younger consciousness that's
more open as well I think we can go into
the theories and topology as to why
people close their doors why people put
up categories of who can get in and we
can again but that's I hope we don't go
into that topic today because there are
some basic stories we need to tell us
yes what are these stories the basic
stories are people are escaping all
kinds of persecution in the homeland yes
because of who they are and because of
climate change people want to have a
better world than themselves and for
their children and that's those are so
primary desire of all human beings
it's just that in the world today even
on national borders we are closing those
doors and therefore refugees and asylum
seekers have become an issue but asylum
seekers and refugees are not asking for
a handout
there are simply people migrating to a
better place to make life better for
their children and their family that's
very profound even just that you kind of
give us this idea of someone just being
born into the world and wanting to when
they look around them they see a lot of
maybe conflict or complexity things that
cause them to want to seek a better life
for themselves and their children and
then this is where maybe refuge and
asylum seeking happens
and not seeking a handout but seeking a
better life for themselves in their
children I like that way framing they
want to be free I mean this is our human
spirit we all want to be free in
whatever way you do it I'm not putting
up a political term tree they want to be
free to be happy to be able to support
themselves explore the world have a
chance for their imagination to to to to
bloom yes so I think this is a basic
human spirit yeah wherever you go that's
why we migrated Out of Africa we have
God human beings have gone out to all
over the world exploration exploration
adventure adventure creativity right so
it's not because they are here knocking
I don't know don't say no give me your
welfare system no they just they think
about themselves they don't think about
what you have they think about who they
are and what they're going to do because
of their love for their family and for
themselves because they're adventurous
there's a human basic human spirit so on
I have a question where were you born
I was born in China where China in south
eastern part of China the reason is
because my grandfather had gone to Sufis
Asia
before the 1900 they he sent for my
father to join him then when my father
was of age he said my father back to
China to marry my mother was a match
make marriage so I was born there and
when I was 2 they took me to Singapore
to join them and then they sent me to
Malaysia my father and my mother went
with me children at that time British
Malaya and that's where I grew up
Wow and so this also in many ways
explains your focus on Southeast Asia
and Asian refuge and asylum seeking okay
so now what's actually going on there's
a lot of conflict let's talk about what
is the conflict that is causing people
to want to do refuge and asylum seeking
and then we can get into the actual
stories and trials there's comfort
everywhere in the world people have
conflict because of differences between
groups and oftentimes the defenses are
created artificially by those in power
and as a result people who want to
search for a better refuge or to be free
they leave their country this is
speaking about people migrating in
general terms what is the interest of
people in power to create artificial
differences to try and move people into
asylum seeking a refuge do they want
their land which they want their
resources will do what do they want why
do people want power what do people seek
more things beyond what they need to
live on to eat if you have one pillow to
sleep on why do you need six pillows if
you need one plate your food why do you
need five plates or if you have one
house to have shelter why do you need
real estate everywhere in the world I
mean then I do not know so I think is
that the greed for power the grip of
resources there they lead to other
people not having some of those things
on preventing other people from having
some of those things so some people must
leave and then the explanation we give
is because oh they are from a global
group of people in society mmm they are
from there they are not one of us yeah
they don't have the same belief they
don't have the same outlook about life
so this is why people persecution that's
the word it seems like the most upstream
issue then is people that have yet to
enlighten and therefore focus more on
greed and dehumanizing and on me
creating the artificial differences that
then cause asylum or refuge which then
make it so that they themselves can do
things like further propagate their
power their wealth so there's a really
deep need we talk about this quite a bit
for these 1500 billionaires on the
planet to have a deeper sense of
interconnectedness unconditional love
architecting the next world but also on
a grassroots level we need to build that
next world as well and I want to let's
do let's do some of the examples are
some of the I think this one at least
has been talked about a little bit but
the ROE Higgins is one of them in
Myanmar this is one of the examples of
people being displaced yes yes
the wrong angles are Muslim and the
country where they came from is me Imam
and most of them are Buddhists
of course the Buddhist could see them as
a Muslim and try to expel them
understand that's the official narrative
but if you were to look at the grass
root level Muslims and Hindus have
always lived next to each other
throughout most of Southeast Asia even
today they are Muslims and Hindus and
Christians who live right next door to
each other so how did it happen in
niyama that's the question I think and
each country has its own story about
exclusion but in go back to your brush
that your question about the grass which
endeavor do we know our neighbors we
worry if our neighbors are Christians or
Buddhists and Muslims for the most part
we don't care it's not an issue we can
still go about our business washing our
cars cooking a meal is going to work we
don't worry about their beliefs and it
is at that point about how can we get
along can we still coexist regardless of
their beliefs what we still go to work
you know go through our you know our
routine every day so it's not in a way
their religion it's not the religion
it's not in a way many things that we
talk about that divide us so how do we
then so I mean go back to your thing
about the the millionaires and
billionaires should they think about
should we try to enlighten them for them
to think about the rest of the world I
don't know I don't know what to do
because I don't know any millionaire but
thing in at the everyday level if the
person happens to meet my neighbor
could I be a French with that person
regardless of the person's wealth the
same way I say can my neighbor be my
friend regardless of the person's
believe so it's that that level
interaction so human I don't think about
you right now
as a person of a different color faith
or wealth so we are able to talk to each
other and explored it's very important
in unique questions about human
condition so how do we reach that level
of our so we use the common analogy that
commonality is so humaneness our human
oneness the love in the hearts dog just
to yeah that unity how do we reach that
how do we make that something common for
not only people at the top of
socioeconomic status top of governments
top of corporations and also on a
grassroots level how do we make it so
when children are born into the world
that those are the things that we
prioritize we talk about this so much
but rather than prioritizing the you
mentioned this as well instead of when
you have one home instead of going for
five or ten homes or five or ten
designer watches or clothes or cars or
boats or planes etc think about the
other gifts that humans can bring into
the world that 50% of them are still
making less than two dollars and fifty
cents a day what if they got patron -
even a thousand dollars from you or
$10,000 from you what could they unleash
creatively into the world that would
make the world a better place
and so I'm very very fascinated with
that exact question and then
architecting the the next protocols that
enable the flow of that enlightened
capital to the artistic endeavoring of
these beautiful hearts of so many people
and then also you know we we started on
we just gave one example of of Muslims
and Buddhists living nearby nearby each
other and being able to find peace in
pluralism versus being able versus
trying to create some sort of
artificial differences that then create
refuge and asylum seeking well I really
want us to get behind the eyes of
specific cases that you write about and
you actually even had a courtroom
attorney who participated in some of the
chapters so yeah teach us about let's
get behind the eyes of some of the
examples and then the complexity of what
the trials are even like well since we
are at the American Anthropological
Association I'm going to talk about what
we do in anthropology so in anthropology
we teach about race we do research on
race culture ethnicity gender religion
issues and these are the subjects our
students learn but in the case of asylum
cases these are the same criteria that
the 1951 UN Convention on refugees
require for people to say I was
persecuted on account of my race my
religion my membership in a particular
social group that usually means gender
issues my nationality in my political
opinion so how can we think about using
anthropology to go into doing work that
assists the asylum seekers who are
seeking refuge okay that's a macro
question we are talking about and I
should tell you also my first case my
first case came about because this woman
from Indonesia she said she was from
Indonesia and she faced all kinds of
turmoil in her homeland and then she
escaped by coming to the US on a tourist
visa then she applied for asylum and the
immigration officer in Anaheim Orange
County said that you have not proof the
year of the Chinese race you said that
you were persecuted because you were
Chinese in Indian
well got proof that your Chinese a child
of the Chinese race but she said how do
I prove myself as a Chinese race and he
said Cohen financial politest
so this woman and her paralegal actually
contacted a forensic anthropologist who
told her that it came to me dead on
arrival I could do some osteoma metric
measurement on you then maybe I could
tell you where you came from but she
said that's not the kind of answer I
want so she contacted me not because
I've done anything like this you know I
teach anthropology general and topology
I teach a course causes on race and
racism causes on Asia and then the first
question she asked me when she came to
my office was can you tell them Chinese
what and topologist talked about race as
a social construct we cannot tell if a
person's of the Chinese race or whatever
so I said I'm not gonna answer the
question then she told me her story
about what had happened to her and how
she fled with 100,000 people in from
Indonesia about you know what about
China towns were burnt and Chinese women
were raped in public so I was thinking
to myself how can I help her I never
done this before I wish on a contact I
don't know but I grew up in Malaysia I
speak the local languages bahasa
malaysia the language of malaysia and
also the language of Indonesia
I also speak several Chinese dialects so
what if I don't know if I don't help her
who will so I said that before and we
had a long interview and I figure out
who she was the other thing was if I
cannot use the word the idea raised in
court then what about using her culture
right if you don't use race as a quite
cheerio if I'm not able to verify her
race what about using coach
as a proxy as a substitute but this
woman came to me without a Chinese name
she didn't speak Chinese she didn't know
how to write Chinese how to prove that
she's of Chinese background so I worked
on that and I wrote a chapter called how
Chinese master Chinese be in the book so
how much do you have to be of Chinese
valuable characteristic in order to be a
Chinese but eventually using a kinship
kinship diagram you see how she
addresses her relatives using how her
mother addresses her cause I was able to
figure that she was indeed of Chinese
origin when you compare her by a process
of elimination she couldn't be another
person from Indonesia so I was able to
do it despite the fact that they did
more year for her and the immigration
officer said we need to prove her race
so I was able to verify that she was of
Chinese background without using idea of
race and the hill trust and the judge
granted her Asylum why why do we even
ask for proof of race and can we use DNA
ancestry can we can't pinpoint where
from hair or saliva the ideal race was
created during the Enlightenment when
the Europeans without the exploring the
world and they came upon people were
quite different from them so at that
time there was a classification of
people based on different so-called
races kaká soy [ __ ] negroid and so
on and those are ideas have been
banished a long time ago
but the idea of race was used during
this during Hitler's regime he was
interested in the purity of
of the race of the superior race so the
ideal race can be pure and others unless
pure came to dominate the thinking or
what we called scientific racism by
thinking that there are some people who
are not of the superior race
we have been racist against them yeah
that's a term we use an anthropology or
scientific racism
so when 1951 UN Convention on refugees
or screeching there's a couple other
decorations before that there was the
counter Hitler's expelling a killing of
no more than six million people in
Europe
besides the Jews the people who were
killed were also people from Poland
people who were handicapped people who
were gay and--but was not pure not part
of the superior race so so the 1951
Refugee Convention was to really to
argue that people who were persecuted
because of their race should be allowed
to have refuge in a different country so
that's there was how he came about but
since then biologists and geneticists
have been looking at the idea of race
and they say human beings are all of the
same race there's no gene for a race the
difference between they're saying give
it to extremes a black and a white
person an african-american and a white
person in the u.s. the difference
between those two individuals is at the
most maybe less than 1% in terms of
differences we share more income
accretion 99.9% in terms of similarity
what and what accounts for the
differences are just a few things such
as skin coloration hair texture there
are lots of things that turn
we share that we don't see so there
isn't really a gene for race there's no
gym for race so biologists and
geneticists don't study race anymore
it's a non-starter so it's a waste of
everybody's time but in the social
sciences in the everyday world the word
race was retained and it has retained
because every nation in the US for
example in 1790 when the census was
pursued the census try to think about
people within the nation can they be
responsible for taxation can they vote
based on the kind of criteria then some
people were given one labor or the other
for instance in 1790 the Chinese were
not considered citizen and they were not
white and therefore there couldn't be
citizens and they were not white
in fact the Chinese were classified once
upon a time as Negro in the US so the
u.s. census created all these
terminologies for people in the US we
can say that race and they don't
ethnicity our really social
constructions of the census of the US
government by way of the US Census
Bureau but war was also out there to
perpetuate what have created earlier so
the US Census Bureau u.s. laws and
social scientists follow the same
pattern of using the word race and using
the same classification let me give you
one example that I found very
interesting when Franz Boas the famous
anthropologist who escaped German Nazis
and came to the US and became the
founder of anthropology at Columbia
University he was asked by the Armenians
in the US to define their race
and Franz Boas said that they were white
well at the time when the Armenians were
classified as white they were able to on
land and they were eventually able to
become citizens and this is really
important the Japanese who were on the
west coast they didn't consult with for
Franz boas they were not allowed to
become citizens they were not allowed to
buy land on land and return by the
Second World War they were interned so
how a person is defined has tremendous
consequences and yet this idea of race
was socially constructed historically to
exclude certain people but today we talk
about all black white you know and so on
and and that's a legacy from this
historical period when race was created
and that we call that social race and I
think we have not done a good job of
reflecting on the on the uselessness of
how that term divides us because if you
were to see two people together we have
a lot more in common than what we are
different and what we are different
maybe a few a few a few minor
characteristics and you and I don't even
care whether the persons are shape a
shape browner or darker or lighter you
know because that really doesn't affect
our our relationship our interaction
their heart and their level of
enlightenment is the most important
thing and you give you give us this
macro level picture of evolution where
it comes to a point of oneness of unity
of the species and then from there then
the social constructs of dividing us by
differences make it so that then it does
in a sense make tight to this point that
you made earlier where people in
positions of power or when the greedy
can point people at each other for those
differences create artificial conflict
and then create refuge and asylum
seeking and you use this word again help
hospitality used these words again when
someone comes knocking in refuge in
asylum I was very surprised when you
said that that there needs to be some
sort of documentation of the person's
race when really it's just another human
and that when the human comes in need of
help and hospitality it's about figuring
out how to provide that help in
hospitality and so that's why this
example of you going through some with
this Indonesian of seeking refuge in the
US and Anaheim it was very surprising to
me no learning about our process there
must be better ways to create help and
hospitality in these circumstances
around the world and because it is for
the human heart and the human
enlightenment to do our best to provide
people with a better life towards
flourishing and their children so this
is one example one of many examples
there are there's a lot more nuance yes
give us some more as well let me just
give you one more example about why
anthropologic expertise is important in
this kind of work so there are women out
there who have claimed that impact in
human oh my a couple of my cases they
claimed that they were they were victims
of horrible sexual violence okay when
that happens we don't have witnesses and
we don't have physical evidence but when
they come to the the the legal system to
apply for asylum so how do we do it
something like that so for me as an
anthropologist the law of course
requires that she must prove persecution
because of the fact that she's of a
gender a woman okay that's what we had
to do so for me as an anthropologist and
say we study culture we study a person's
a role and position within a society
so I solve the problem of this woman and
that case is mentioned in the book
I solved the problem by thinking about
her and how she felt so ashamed in the
community she was so ashamed she could
not even face a husband and they didn't
have a relationship for a long time she
said every time he tried to touch on her
shoulder
she would say I'm tired she was so
ashamed she ran and escaped and live in
her sister's house and nobody could see
her or know her and she took her
daughter go tell people I've moved to a
different country so on on her fiscal on
her face from her physical appearance he
cannot tell that something had happened
to her there was a violation of her her
sin Chi Chi in terms of how she sees
herself so when I listen to her stories
and the trauma that she had gone through
so I wrote about how she felt so
shameful it was a shame that defined her
life that structure her everyday
behavior and at OU that story I wrote
the story for the for the judge and for
the government attorney because they
read that document and she was crying to
asylum I was so happy so in other words
the judges and their lawyers this asana
adjudicators they're human beings too
they listen they can relate with those
stories as much as people - oh they are
fraudulent yeah economic migrants they
want to be here because they want to
we're gonna get a piece of the American
power but how do you account for the
fact that there are judges and lawyers
who also give them asylum not because I
did a good job of proving that they were
persecuted because of this other but in
somewhere along the line they myself
opened the heart
yes they must have seen that something
something really horrible happened to
her yes it happened but also the fact
that she
wounded as a person and that the
adjudicators can relate to that human
beings can be in winter and they also
want something better this is why I'm
optimistic that that that the system
works as much as I know how typically
cheese for asylum seekers to win asylum
I love the focus on healing these
traumatic experiences and when in need
of help we provide hospitality towards
healing towards growth and towards
evolution and we can build a better
future together that way we give us an
idea of some of these numbers how many
asylum adjudicators are there in the
u.s. how many people seek asylum or
refuge in the u.s. maybe per year do we
have an idea of these numbers the
numbers are out there but have not been
keeping track of the numbers and know
that we have been emitting fewer and
fewer refugees in the u.s. we used to be
the biggest refugee takers in the world
used to be and how many was that we know
approximately no we took him up to the
Vietnam War we took it we took it over a
million refugees from Vietnam we took in
a lot of Haitians and then people from
Central America we give him temporary
protective status GPS so we've been
taking them in one fashion or the other
but this past two years our number for
refugees have gone down tremendously
I cannot even I don't quote that number
because it was so long it was
embarrassing there's a colleague of mine
who has been working with a refugee and
she was looking at support for this
young man and she had to reach out to
different people and
she reached out to the presiding bishop
span all the way to the top and say she
had funding for this young man in my
university with when it's helpful
besides housing you know school fees and
they say yes we have them funding
because we have not been supporting
refugees going to the u.s. so it's that
kind of level under Latino in terms that
yes repercussions and in the way in this
case this is a good repercussion for
this young man but so we are not taking
as many because I don't have pertinent
number the numbers keep changing the
refugee laws keep changing in the US so
I was gonna ask you that next what are
the refugee and asylum seeking laws in
the United States and how did they defer
between countries as well some countries
in the world have signed into the 1951
Refugee Convention and then they also
they also signed on to the 1987 I'm not
sure what's the term the amendment that
updates the 1951 convention because
there was for people escaping Europe and
then since then other countries people
can come to protocol 1987 protocol okay
so so so some countries do and some
countries don't so let me give you one
example
in the case of Malaysia Malaysia because
the u.s. is a member of the Refugee
Convention can we accept refugees of
these protocols yes and how many
countries are part of these protocols do
we know I I don't know I mean most of
the most of my Western European
countries okay so Germany in France
Italy UK Sweden Norway and there's some
sort of asylum adjudication process that
between each nation with initiation that
follows the protocols yes okay so in the
case of Malaysia Malaysia is not did not
sign on to this protocol so then you
have large number rolling guns and
Syrians right now in Malaysia in fact
170,000 asylum seekers who are raw
England's Syrians
Afghans in Malaysia they are registered
with the United Nations High
Commissioner for Refugees UNHCR so they
are living in Malaysia they are not
living in refugee camps they are
scattered throughout the community by
housing whenever they can but because
they are not recognized by the Malaysian
government they cannot work legally so
the big companies they want to hire them
but they are afraid to bring immolation
law because they cannot hire them
legally because they are not recognized
as refugees in Malaysia so this is a
typical bind for the asylum seekers it's
a difficult situation by the UNHCR they
don't have jurisdiction over Malaysian
law yeah and the Malaysian politicians I
mean why do politicians do what they do
I don't know there are many reasons I
don't want to explore I'm looking
formulation rep Allah teaches to say you
know what there are neighbors right they
are here already they're not in refugee
camps they want to contribute an
amendment to enable them to work why not
why not they're already working it's
just that they are working illegally and
therefore they exploit by the employers
versus legally yes yes versus legally
vacant they can improve their condition
and lot better the u.s. opened the jaws
to the Vietnamese 35 40 years ago we did
them and look at what happened today to
the Vietnamese there they are one of the
most successful groups they are our
doctors and optometrists and dentists
and teachers and engineers in our
community the same with the Haitians
right and the Cubans especially in
Florida so we have done a great job and
we think about the other people who came
from other countries from
and from the UK from Ireland from Italy
they are part of the makeup of the US
and what makes America great is all the
people who say the system in my country
didn't quite work I'm coming here to
make the system better so if you think
about the asylum seekers and refugees
today knocking on our door here we are
doing the same thing they are the quick
cheat of the systems they have not
worked elsewhere and they are saying you
want to make that make things better so
I do under see them as abstract numbers
or in a negative way I see them as
people with such clarity about what's
going on and were able to create what is
wrong in the system yeah if the
hospitality is provided at these times
of need of help then it can make it so
that all these unique meant this melting
pot of creative gifts that can be
brought to upgrade the system can
actually be actualized and brought forth
and that's a really beautiful way to to
view it and put it yeah we're all part
of the moral community yeah yeah the the
other thing that you mentioned there was
that you can take these on the
individual story by story basis of
getting behind the eyes which is
extremely important and we can also do
things like take it on to larger numbers
also to hopefully entice other people to
care more about this and we were talking
about this just a little bit ago but
these refugee camps around the planet
we're not even talking about people
coming and knocking on the door seeking
a refuge or asylum and seeking greater
economic flourishing for themselves and
their children but we're talking about
camps filled with hundreds of thousands
of people around the world where it's
just stuck in the camp
yes itself and if you view any of these
photos there's like the Dobb refugee
camp there's many of these with hundreds
of thousands of people where it is like
little shanty towns yes and it's it's
not Munir with the utmost privilege
compared to that and we need to be very
aware and and respectful to that
privilege and then use that privilege to
support redesigning the social fabric so
that more people can be uplifted faster
into greater flourishing that's the bird
that's the burden on that we have yes on
us that's why I wrote the book for my
students it's a young people who will
need to take on that responsibility to
help out I want to ask you another
question this is probably the last
question we can revisit this as we
hopefully continue featuring people that
are studying specific such beautiful
specific anthropological macro movements
like this as well as on a micro level
getting behind the perspective of all of
the individuals eyes so we can better
understand our humanity and how to build
the next world the last question I
really like asking our guests is what do
you think is most beautiful that you're
able to sit next to each other and
talking and having a conversation I it's
a privilege
I'm happy about this opportunity the
fact that we are talking about
a very typical human condition I like to
have more opportunities to talk about
that I'm really happy that you answer it
that way we can find the peace and
harmony and dialogue that happens
between humans on how to build the next
world we can make it happen together and
enjoy these heart-to-heart interactions
I love it so on thank you thank you very
much thank you for coming on the show
and all your great work thank you thank
you thank you thanks everyone for tuning
in we greatly appreciate it we'd love to
hear your thoughts in the comments below
in the episode let us know what you're
thinking check out the links in the bio
below two identities on trial in the
United States you can find the link in
the bio below and you can find all of
Swann's other links in the bio below and
also support the American
Anthropological Association as well you
can find their links in the bio below
you can also find simulations links in
the bio below eating has helped support
us so we can continue doing cool things
like coming on site to great places like
triple a's annual meeting to interview
their leadership you can find us on
paypal patreon cryptocurrency key design
cool merch you get paid all those things
in the bio below and go and build the
future everyone manifest your dreams
into the world we love you very much
thank you for tuning in and we will see
you soon hey everyone before we end this
episode with Swan I would like to
introduce Nancy conv linka she is a
professor of anthropology at the
national distance education University
in Madrid Spain and along with her
colleague Raoul Sanchez they are editors
of the Lexington book series with this
theme crossing borders in a global world
applying anthropology to migration
displacement and social change who Swan
is one of the authors in this book
series and we would like to talk about
this book series a little bit the
purpose of it and what else is going to
be released in 2020 Thank You Nancy
thank you very much I'm very glad to be
here we we are really excited about this
book series because it's not just
another book series on migration
we want to get theoretical
methodological approaches but we also
want the books to have a practical
nature as was very obvious in in swans
research where she is using her research
to give expert witness for cases that go
before court and actually do things for
real people so that's part of it I'm not
all anthropology is is applied but this
is one of the areas where applied
anthropology can be very interesting
we're also looking in the series at
migration in a very broad sense so we
can be talking about economic migration
about people who migrate for all sorts
of other reasons that are not
necessarily economic sometimes looking
for a better situation sometimes simply
pursuing a career that is easier to
carry out in one place or another or
even reproductive migration people who
travel from one part of the world to
another seeking reproductive services or
seeking to provide reproductive services
that they are not allowed in their own
countries or that are too expensive in
their own countries so we're looking at
all of these different areas so we think
it's it's a new series that brings
together to kind of different areas in
that way and also has a very strong
applied aspect to it yeah I love the
focus on the apply to anthropological
side of it plus I loved how you broke
down all these other reasons for
migration and also just we were talking
about this earlier with so on on up so
just getting behind the eyes of all
these individual cases that are so
diverse it's gonna be a very interesting
series I'm one of the books that's also
out with Swans right now in the series
is crux of refugee settlement rebuilding
social networks exactly it's an edited
volume the editors are Andrew Nelson
from the University of North Texas
Alexander Ruud like from Creighton
University and Bruce Williams of the
University of Leuven and it's a book
that talks about
refugees are resetting in other areas
and exactly what processes they go
through and implement with with their
own agency to do this how people depend
on relatives who have already settled
there how they create community centers
and one of the very interesting things
about this book is that it has a lot of
participant anthropology meaning meaning
in this case that after each author
writes his or her chapter hmm there is a
commentary by someone who is a non
anthropologist who was also involved in
the research in some cases it can be a
social scientist who was there a social
worker in many cases they're the very
community leaders or different people
who do participate in the community of
the refugees who have resettled talking
about the authors analysis so we're not
just getting an anthropologists cold
analysis of of something that's
happening perhaps but people from the
community commenting on what this
anthropologist is saying whether they
agree whether they disagree whether
there are other areas they think should
be considered also so it's an another
exciting book and again a little bit
different from from what is usually just
a plain ethnographic analysis yeah I
love the application of wanting a study
how the formation of social networks
happen of a refugee or migrant as we
were just talking about this on a very
recent episode with Augustin Fuentes and
when we talked about how the greatest
indicator of people's happiness at the
end of their lives is how many close
friends that they had though yeah I
thought that was one of the really
interesting studies yeah exactly and how
those actually forms of social networks
form in such a migratory especially
having a family myself that came
at the 25-year point of her life from
Armenia to the United States had me here
so I see her doing that exact same
process of making a social network at
some at a point in 25 that I point in
her life as well as my uncle and
grandmother um it's so interesting yes
it's so interesting awesome so the the
series will have approximately six more
books of they're under preparation right
now right we have six more authors that
have sent us their proposals and they've
all been really interesting they're
they're finishing up writing the
chapters now and we hope to get these
books out in 2020 and we are always
interested in book proposals that are
based on ethnographic work because we
always insist in anthropology that you
can't just speculate about something you
have to have talked and worked with real
people who are in that situation in
order to be able to give a nuanced
detailed analysis of what's really going
on and avoid all those big categories
that don't really serve people on the
ground who need things done so so there
we're always looking for projects that
are ethnographic projects that deal with
any aspect at all of migration and we're
looking forward to a long life as a book
series and to many many more
publications Wow okay so ethnic
ethnographic publications of migration
may also reach out to you or the series
okay so reach out in that context also
the links in the bio will be below for
both Swann's book as well as who is the
author of the crooks there it's it's an
edited book by three authors andrew
nelson alexander rudakov Andrews
Williams okay great and so that book
link will also be in the bio below and
then there is also is there a main page
for the theme as well there actually is
it's there's a page on the Lexington web
page I will send you the link so that it
can be there
- excellent excellent so all those
things in the Bible oh and thank you
very much for tuning in again to the
episode with Swan and do check out the
somatic book series again that Nancy was
teaching us about thank you everyone
thank you very much
[Music]
you
[Music]
thank you so much thank you so much for
having me it really was nice okay thank
you
you